23 maggio 18 18 k ho visto io mica male
uno io ora sono le diffide da k
non è vero valore medio di kakà di
grappa io una carta speciale perché io
ho il joker e il joker vince sotto
cos'era questo rumore
[Musica]
mi sembra già pensata da sotto cosa
pensi che possa essere a quest ora lo so
forse un gatto un gatto da dove è
entrato ha fatto rumore
magari il marino che lo stia inseguendo
no berlino sta dormendo età né per lui
mi chiama se c'è qualche altro al rumore
è meglio che andiamo a controllare
io non voglio andare però come facciamo
facciamo carta forbito il grasso mi è
venuta un'idea forte perché controlliamo
le camere di sicurezza
ottima idea abbiamo anche qui il tablet
prendere reti allegati qua ecco la
camera di sicurezza dal piano di sotto
ma chi è che mi e ci credo che cosa sto
facendo con quella cosa in mano cosa ci
fa al piano di sotto
[Musica]
e quella sta mettendo una rete
quello è una scatola gigante
[Musica]
sta portando un sacco di spazzatura a
tutti i sacchetti sembra contento perché
sto mettendo tutti quei cartoni che se
vuole fare la sua casa a cui va fiero
addosso senza come sembra una casa una
casa di cartone un fortino adesso
qualcosa una trappola sport
[Musica]
ho visto la camera ed io sono corsa di
sicurezza
però non possiamo più controllare cosa
sta facendo dobbiamo per forza a
scendere a controllare anche scendiamo
tutti e due anche berlino viene ed è in
pericolo
quindi forse è meglio se pato solo io mi
sembra un'ottima idea vincente sono
state tu sei coraggiosa tanto certo i
motori per difenderti dai guantoni per
difendesi così se sei episodi albero
degli le due pugni gradi ma sicuro che
può essere una buona idea sip almeno
questi non fanno troppo male albero di
rifiuti un po non so se sia una buona
idea poi non posso neanche tenere la
videocamera in mano per farti vedere
quello che sta succedendo allora ometti
del in tasca così quando hai bisogno poi
era in di libri di togliere non penso
che ci scrive marca sono scomodi via
libera allora va via io cercavo solo di
difendersi o semplicemente controllare
cosa sta facendo che apro solo la porta
e controllo che si sta facendo anche se
io un sospetto secondo me sta costruendo
un box sport o una sorta di escape room
qualcosa del genere e aprire una porta e
controllare questa sta facendo g tour a
far tempo cerca di sistemare
carichi sicurezza almeno puoi
controllare cosa succede però però tempo
che hai tu stai attenta che non sento
più rumori di prendi paura che se ne sia
andata abbia lasciato quella cosa che
sfruttino forse qua dietro la porta i
ragazzi anche se non si vede niente
qua c'è la porta
eccola
chissà
[Musica]
ecco mi nascondo che sta facendo
no
tale forse è meglio settore massucco non
posso lasciarla continuare a costruire
quella cosa fa in casa nostra
[Musica]
chi
venire forma
[Musica]
ma sono che schifo che cos'era
quest'oro sembrò dentro una scatola di
cartone che cosa è questa la cosa finito
col dentro ei c'è nessuna ora ho capito
credimi ha preso e mi ha rinchiuso nella
sua strana costruzione di cartone come
faccia uscire da qua faccio aiuto cioè
nessuno devo trovare una chiave qualcosa
senza fare in modo che se ne accorga
anche i treni però cerchiamo ti
fideresti mese troviamo qualche chiave
qualcosa premia la chiave ho sentito il
rumore
siccome faccio guardate cosa nota
[Musica]
ehi c'è nessuna come faccio
riuscirà uscire forse qui prima
possibile
[Musica]
c'è nessuno che tutto faccia uscire di
qui
[Musica]